When people watch my documentary, they
all want to know, "How did you make him
so consistent?"
I'm here with the star of my V3
documentary to show you how I generated
consistent characters in V3.
They're going to want to know how you
did this part, too. Yeah, you're right.
All right. This intro I did in Runway.
V3 currently doesn't support character
references, which is the easiest way to
create consistent characters. So, I'm
going to show you what I did. And the
foundation came from my previous video
called Wonderful Dream, which I created
in Whisk. And the character from that
makes a cameo in this movie. All right.
So, this is Whisk, and it's a tool from
Google that lets you generate images,
and then you can generate videos from
those images. Um, this is what I made
Wonderful Dream in. So, this was the
final prompt that I used um to create
one image of the character. So, I didn't
use it as a reference image, but I had
to create an image of that character.
This is what I used. So, if we were
using character reference images, we
would expect this image to be what the
character in the video looks like. But
all we're doing really is taking these
characters and then we're going to go
over here to the subject and drag it
over here. And why are we doing that?
So, it's going to analyze this image and
it's going to give us a much more robust
prompt. So, this is what it sees. So,
this is kind of how the Google AI
universe sees this image. So, this
became the basis for my prompt. I took
all of it over to Gemini and I attached
this photo and I said, "Here's a prompt
I wrote in Whisk." and I gave it my
prompt. And then it said, "Here is the
image description I received for this
image." And I put that image description
in there. And then I said, "I would like
a detailed VO3 description of just the
man that I can use in a template for
building prompts where I try to place
him in a consistent looking way." So
don't worry about the wardrobe. Just
focus on his face. Just to recap, here's
the image. Here's the prompt I gave.
Here's the image description from Whisk
and give me something to use
consistently. So, I just asked, "What do
you think his name would be and how
would you write a voice prompt for him
in VO3?" Cuz I want to have a consistent
voice all the time. It thinks about it.
It says Aram. And I was like, "Okay,
cool." Like, I'm not going to I'm not
fuss with you. Let's call him Aram. And
then it gave me some options for his
voice. Here's an example of the full
prompt. So it gives you the physical
description of him. And then when he
speaks, this is um how he talks. And I
wanted a certain style. So I said,
"Please provide a core prompt for Aram,
core prompt for Aram's voice, and a core
prompt for a cinematic style shot in
35mm." This is for the visual or
physical description of him. This is
what his voice would sound like.
Slightly raspy and grally, tinged with
thoughtful curiosity. All right. Now, do
a prompt in a high-end documentary style
where he says, "I used to wake up and
worry about all of the things I needed
to do that day." And it gave me this.
I used to wake up and worry about all of
the things I needed to do that day. So,
that's kind of it for consistent
characters. Build a very detailed
description of the character and use
that in all of the prompts. Okay. So,
the trick is using the same detailed
character description in the prompt, but
how do you get rid of these subtitles?
The other big thing that people have a
problem with are the captions. So, I
heard on Discord that if you use Gemini
to generate the videos, you don't see
the captions. So, I tried that in the
first one. There were no captions and I
was excited. And then I did it again and
I got captions. So, that didn't work.
So, I wanted to try an AI way to get rid
of the captions. So even if VO3
generated it with captions, I can remove
them with AI. So the first one I tried
was Runway's inpainting tool. You've got
a brush over here. Just go to the
captions and just kind of wipe the brush
over the captions and then they
disappear. So you can kind of, in my
opinion, you can kind of see a little
bit when it adjusts there. But it's
better than nothing. Like if you didn't
know it was there, you might not notice.
like if you didn't know to look at that
spot, you might not see it because
you're watching him talk. So, that was
okay. But then I remembered that Cap Cut
also has something similar. Um, I use
Cap Cut. I think it's a great AI editor.
So, in Cap Cut, I just put the video on
my editing timeline as I'm editing the
video. I selected it. I went to video
and I scrolled down here to where it
says AI remove. I checked that. It takes
a second to recognize the video. I
selected one of the brushes. So, I did
the quick brush, just kind of like moved
it over and boom, it did that. So, I put
a little like box around it even. Then I
said remove him. And look at that. Like
even in the collar, it didn't like
there's all of these lines in the collar
and it it's pretty it's pretty smooth.
So, I think that the cap cut one worked
terrific. Okay. And then lastly, one of
the problems I had with his voice was, I
think, because he's described as an
Armenian farmer. It would give him
different accents. I had a lot of jobs.
My favorite ones were being a butcher
and being a barber. And I really liked
the voices that I created in the
documentary interview styles. So, I
combined a few clips of him in order to
get 10 seconds and exported just the
audio. Then, I brought that into 11
Labs. And 11 Labs will let you clone a
voice with only 10 seconds of audio. I
added the clip of him talking and
generated a voice is called the Aram. So
I exported all of the audio where he's
talking and brought that into 11 Labs
and used their voice changer. And what I
was hoping would happen is that he would
lose his accent and it would sound like
the same character. So that didn't
really happen. Some of the videos had an
accent to them and so I just typed in
and did like text to speech for those
until I found ones that were close
enough to the same timing where I could
just drop those in. So it's kind of
cheating I know in terms of like it's
not the same generated audio, but um it
is generated audio and I think that
having a consistent voice as well as a
consistent face really helps sell it.
It's not that I dislike reality.
It's just there's more than one reality.
It used to be 100 credits for every
video in V3 and now you can actually do
the fast ones. And some of the fast ones
turned out just as good as the pro ones
in my opinion. Sometimes too, the fast
ones gave me like really weird surreal
things. Like this one was not what I
wanted to do, but it was kind of uh very
bizarre. feel like this one was done in
the fast one. This is one of my favorite
shots in the whole thing. And this was
done on the fast mode.
If you're wondering where to change
that, you go here to the settings
button, and you can choose between
three, V3 fast, which shows you it's 20
credits, or V3 quality, which is 100.
So, I hope this helps you create
consistent characters in V3. And if you
enjoy this kind of thing, please
subscribe because I like to make movies
and I like to do tutorials about how I
made those movies. All right, before I
show your blooper reel, do you have any
final wisdom? Is this where I'm supposed
to say smash that subscribe button? I
don't think people say that anymore. All
right, let's watch some Bad Generations.
All right, thank you for watching. Um,
if you're interested in any of the tools
that I use today, please check the
description. and I put links to
different things in there. All right, go
make some consistent characters in VO3.
[Music]